قال مسؤولو الأمم المتحدة اليوم إن 70٪
من الناس في قطاع الجونا
مشردون، كثيرون في حالة معيشية يعيشون
في ظروف بيان يسمى
اقتباس غير إنساني قال الأمين العام إن
جونزا أصبحت
مقبرة اقتباس للأطفال
سفير إسرائيل لدى الأمم المتحدة أه انتقده
دعا أولئك الموجودون في التعليقات إلى
استقالة الأمين العام إميلي سي
كالاهان، وهي مديرة نشاط ممرضة في منظمة أطباء
بلا حدود، لقد تم إجلاؤها يوم
الأربعاء الماضي وعادت إلى
الولايات المتحدة خلال عطلة
نهاية الأسبوع، أولاً، ما هو شعورك
بالخروج كثيرًا  من الأشخاص يستمرون في سؤالي عن ذلك،
وليس لدي حقًا إجابة جيدة،
من الواضح أن لدي شعور بالارتياح
لأنني في المنزل وأنا مع عائلتي
وأشعر بالأمان لأول مرة منذ 26
يومًا  من الصعب حقًا
العثور على أي متعة في أي شيء من هذا، لأنني أشعر
بالأمان نتيجة اضطراري إلى
ترك الناس خلفهم، الأشخاص الذين
يشاهدون هذا، لقد شاهدوا صورًا من غزة، لقد شاهدوا
صور المستشفى، لقد
شاهدوا رعب الأطفال
الموتى  يومًا بعد يوم بعد يوم بعد يوم،
أعني أنهم شاهدوا كل
الصور، ولكن لكي تكون هناك بالفعل
وتجربتها، فإنك تختبر كل
هذه الأشياء التي لا يمكن للكاميرا
التقاطها أبدًا، لذا هل يمكنك التحدث قليلاً
عن الموقف عندما  تغمض
عينيك في الليل ما الذي تفكر فيه
الآن
أعتقد أن الإجابة على هذا السؤال
أعتقد أنني سأبدأ في kytc حيث تم
نقلنا حوالي خمس مرات
على مدار 26 يومًا بسبب
مخاوف أمنية و  أحد الأماكن التي
انتهينا منها كان مركز تدريب القانون الذي
نطلق عليه اسم kytc، وذلك عندما
تم إجلاء الناس إلى الجنوب، لذلك
كنت في الجنوب عندما ذهبنا إلى الغرب
أسفل خط غرب غزة، وبحلول
الوقت الذي غادرنا فيه كان هناك  كان هناك 35,000
نازح داخليًا يعيشون
بجانبنا، وكان هناك أطفال مصابون
بحروق شديدة في وجوههم وأسفل
أعناقهم وفي جميع أنحاء أطرافهم،
ونظرًا لاكتظاظ المستشفيات، فقد تم
إخراجهم
فورًا وتم إخراجهم إلى
هذه المخيمات دون إمكانية الوصول إليهم.
المياه الجارية هناك 50.000 شخص في هذا المخيم
الآن في أربعة مراحيض، ويتم إعطاؤهم
ساعتين من المياه كل 12 ساعة ونحن نقوم بتوفير
المراحيض لـ 50.000 شخص، نعم،
وهذا هو المكان الذي كنا نعيش فيه أيضًا
ولديهم حروق وجروح مفتوحة جديدة
وعمليات بتر جزئي  الذين
يتجولون فقط في هذه الظروف
ويحضر الآباء أطفالهم
إلينا للذهاب من فضلك، هل يمكنك المساعدة من فضلك، هل
يمكنك المساعدة وليس لدينا أي إمدادات عندما نكون في
المواقف التي يوجد فيها عشرات
الآلاف من الأشخاص وهي حرب
والناس لا يفعلون ذلك  لا يستطيعون إطعام أطفالهم،
تصبح الأمور غريبة بسرعة كبيرة وتصبح الأمور
صعبة للغاية بسرعة كبيرة وينقلب الناس
على بعضهم البعض، لقد رأيت ذلك عن قرب
في kytc، لقد كنا السبب وراء اضطرارنا
للمغادرة هو أننا بدأنا نتعرض
للمضايقات.  الأشخاص اليائسون الذين
يفقدون أحباءهم يمينًا ويسارًا
غاضبون وكانوا يشيرون إلي
ويصرخون أمريكيًا يمر بجانبي، وفي تلك
المرحلة لم تكن لدينا أي فكرة عما سيأتي في
الأيام القليلة المقبلة وأه كانوا يصرخون
بأشياء باللغة العبرية لمعرفة ما إذا كان  كنا
إسرائيليين أم اتهموا
موظفينا الوطنيين إما بالخونة أو قالوا
إنك تتظاهر بأنك عربي نحن
نعلم أنك تتظاهر بأنك
عربي فقط توقف عن الكذب علينا وكان على موظفينا
الدفاع عن أنفسهم وقلنا  لهم
مرارًا وتكرارًا، ليس عليك
البقاء، نحن نفهم إذا كنت تريد أن تتركنا،
وقالوا إنك من العائلة أيضًا
ولن نذهب إلى أي مكان، موظفيك، كان
الفلسطينيون الذين يعملون في منظمة أطباء
بلا حدود في منظمة أطباء بلا حدود قلقين
بخصوص سلامتك كنا سنموت
في غضون أسبوع بدونهم، إنهم
السبب الوحيد الذي يجعلنا على قيد الحياة، إنه أمر
لا يصدق أن هذا استغرق وقتًا طويلاً حتى يبدأ
المرضى الأمريكيون في التحرك
عبر معبر رافا الحدودي، إنه أمر لا
يمكن تفسيره وكنا يائسين  لقد
قمنا بإحصاء السعرات الحرارية في وقت ما
بناءً على إمداداتنا واكتشفنا
أنه إذا كان لدينا جميعًا 50 شخصًا
يعيشون معنا في موقف للسيارات، فإننا الآن نأكل
700 سعرة حرارية فقط في اليوم، وإذا كان هذا هو كل ما لدينا،
فسيتبقى لدينا طعام لمدة يومين و  هذا كل شيء،
وانطلق موظفونا الوطنيون،
ولم يكن لدينا خدمة خلوية في تلك المرحلة، لذلك
لم تكن لدينا أي فكرة عما حدث لهم، هناك
قنابل تنفجر من حولنا
لأنه لا يوجد مكان آمن في غزة
حتى عبر معبر رفح الحدودي،
ماذا كان ذلك؟  كما لو أنهم لم
يتركوا جانبنا للحظة واحدة، أنتم
الموظفون الوطنيون لأنهم كانوا يخشون على
سلامتكم حتى عند معبر AC الحدودي، لقد
تأكدوا من أنهم
يقفون بيننا وبين الأشخاص اليائسين،
وتأكدوا من أنهم يتحدثون إلى
كل مسؤول  أنهم قد يجدون أنهم
يحاولون دفعنا خلال محاولة
إيصالنا إلى الحافلة ومحاولة إخراجنا ونحن
نقف هناك ونشاهد
هؤلاء الرجال الرائعين الذين ضحوا
بكل شيء من أجلنا والذين ضحوا
بوقتهم مع عائلاتهم
السلامة الجسدية إمدادات المياه الخاصة بهم التي
كانوا يقدمونها لنا ونحن
نشاهدهم وهم يقاتلون لإيصالنا عبر
الحدود وهم يعلمون أننا لم
نحضرهم معنا ولم يفعلوا ذلك ولم
يترددوا أم أن إبراهيم كان في المقدمة مباشرة
معنا  كانت جوازات سفرنا تتقاتل بشدة من أجل إقناعنا بالتواصل،
ووصلنا إلى الأيرلنديين في تلك الليلة
واكتشفنا أن والديه ماتا،
وكانا يفقدان أفرادًا من العائلة
والأصدقاء، كما قلت لولا
موظفيك الوطنيين، كنت تعتقد أنك كنت
ستُقتل MH  من قبل أشخاص كانوا
يائسين، إما كنا
سنموت جوعا أو نفاد الماء،
كانوا هم الذين تفاوضوا على كل ذلك،
غزة مدينة صغيرة لذا
الجميع يعرف الجميع وكانوا
يدعون ويتصلون بأصدقائهم
ويقولون من  هل تعلم أن لديه طعامًا
ومن تعرف أنه مفتوح أين يمكننا
الحصول عليه وكانوا يقودون سياراتهم في كل
مكان للعثور على المياه وعندما
نفدت المياه المعبأة لدينا في غزة، كانوا هم من
تمكنوا من معرفة
ذلك  كانت شاحنة المياه تأتي إلى هنا في
هذه الأوقات وأعلم أن هذا الرجل يعمل في
محل بقالة وما زال لديهم
الطاقة في بعض الأحيان أعتقد أنه ربما يمكنني
الحصول على شيء منهم مثلما نفعل عندما
أقول إننا كنا سنموت جوعًا
بدونهم.  أنا لا أبالغ،
ففي لحظات اليأس المطلق
للمدنيين كانوا صامدين وهادئين
وتحدثوا معهم للتو وقالوا إن هؤلاء
الأشخاص أيضًا في نفس القارب، ليس
لديهم أي إمدادات،
وليس لديهم طعام وماء أيضًا.
ينامون أيضًا في الخارج على الخرسانة وقد فعلوا
ذلك
بطريقة جميلة بحيث تمكنوا من
التحدث معهم بالحب واللطف
ولم يكن هناك عنف في قلوبهم
وهدأ كل من حولهم
أيضًا هل ستعود إلى غزة في  نبض
قلب في نبض مطلق أه
قلبي في غزة وسيبقى في غزة
الشعب الفلسطيني الذي عملت
معه مع كل من موظفينا الوطنيين في
المكتب وكذلك الموظفين العاملين معي في
مستشفى إندونيسيا كانوا من أكثر
الأشخاص الرائعين الذين قابلتهم على الإطلاق  التقيت في
حياتي عندما انقطع كل شيء
وتلقينا إشعارًا بالتحرك جنوب
غزة، كنت أرسل رسالة نصية إلى ممرضاتي في
مستشفى إندونيسيا وقلت إننا فقدنا
ممرضة في عطلة نهاية الأسبوع في أحد الأيام، قُتل
عندما خرجت سيارة الإسعاف خارج المستشفى
تم تفجيره وكنت أرسل رسالة نصية عندما
تلقينا أوامر الإخلاء وقلت هل
انتقل أي منكم إلى الجنوب، هل خرج أي منكم، هل
نزل أي منكم بهذه
الطريقة والإجابة الوحيدة التي حصلت عليها هي أن هذا
هو مجتمعنا، هذا هو  عائلتنا،
هؤلاء هم
أصدقاؤنا، إذا كانوا سيقتلوننا،
فسوف نموت لإنقاذ أكبر عدد
ممكن من الناس، وقلت إذا كان بإمكاني الحصول على
ذرة
من القلب الذي تملكه، فسوف
أموت سعيدًا  لقد كان شخصًا رائعًا،
أود أن أرسل تذكيرًا بأن
هناك مدنيين يبحثون عن مأوى
هناك وأن الأطباء والممرضات
لم يغادروا المكان بسبب ولائهم
لمجتمعهم، وأنا أعلم أن هناك
فكرة يتم دفعها الآن بأن أي شخص
سيتم اعتبار الذين بقوا في الخلف
نوعًا من التهديد وأريد
أن أذكر الناس بأن الأشخاص
الذين بقوا في الخلف هم أبطال، والأشخاص
الذين بقوا في الخلف يعرفون أنهم
سيموتون
ويختارون البقاء في الخلف
على أي حال  أنت تتحدث عن الأطباء
والممرضات في
المستشفى، أستيقظ كل صباح
وأرسل رسالة نصية وأسألك هل
أنت على قيد الحياة وكل ليلة قبل أن
أنام أرسل رسالة أخرى وأقول
هل أنت على
قيد الحياة جيدًا كيل، شكرًا لك.  الكثير على
وقتك شكرا لك